reaction former Arkansas Governor Mike
Huckabee and fo Fox News contributor Ari
fer good to see you both Governor
Huckabee I mean I think everything that
we could possibly say about Joe Biden
has been said but when you see this and
it is look whatever cognitive issues he
has it is degenerative it never gets
better it only gets worse it seems to
the getting worse part seems to have
accelerated in recent months would you
agree with that
it' be hard not to agree with that I'm
just sitting here watching thinking man
I sure picked the wrong year not to run
for president I should have gone ahead
and done it now uh you know this is this
is really dist you're saying confidently
you would have beaten Donald Trump I I
know you like Trump you're telling
Donald Trump on national TV tonight
you'd beat him nah no no way uh I'm
supporting him and have been since he
announced for re-election and supported
him in 2016 he he's really the best hope
we have to get this country back on
track secure the Border make it so that
people can afford their bacon butter and
and bread which they can't do right now
for the most part unless they have Joe
Biden's salary which most Americans
don't this is a tragedy and the tragedy
is is the Democrats and the media keep
covering for him and I think the more
that the American people see what you
just showed they're going to look at
this and those numbers with blacks
Hispanics and young people are only
going to continue to Crater for Joe
Biden people look at this and they say I
don't care whether I like this guy can't
even say if I like his policies which I
can't imagine they would but this man is
not capable of leading the country I I
think of watching a scene from the six
sense and Haley Joel osmet and he looks
around he says I see dead people that's
who he sees he sees miton instead of
seeing macron I mean this is bizarre
stuff well I I agree with every bit of
it I I think maybe what is even more
interesting is his vice president vice
president Harris Ari fleser her approval
rating is lower than his how's that
possible yeah that's really an
accomplishment isn't it and if I'm
Donald Trump I will remind everybody
that it's highly likely that Kamala
Harris will be the president of the
United States if Joe Biden somehow is
able to win the election that will scare
a lot of people but I want to go to this
issue Sean because it's so much worse
than him not remembering the name of
Hamas if you had actually begun that
tape about 10 seconds earlier what you
would have witnessed was the United
States President struggling to recall
the briefing he got about the status of
negotiations between Israel and Hamas he
could not remember the details he saw
the wheels turning in his head the
cobwebs trying to be swept out of the
way he couldn't remember it he was
struggling the same thing happen Sean in
the leadup to the Afghanistan withdrawal
he he said that nobody in the military
told him he could have left a smaller
number of troops in Afghanistan and
therefore maybe saved those lives of the
13 Marines he said nobody told him that
was an option and then he was
contradicted by his own military saying
no he was briefed about that this is
what happens when the president cannot
recall his briefings it's deadly serious
it's not just he didn't remember the
name of Hamas he doesn't remember the
things he's told earlier hours earlier
in the Oval Office that puts all
Americans in danger that's the problem
with the president at that
age all right so I'll throw it to you
Ari first we're 271 days away from
election day all right does he survive
till that that point do you do you buy
into any of these I I would argue that
they're just educated guesses of people
that that the Democrats maybe at the
convention will look to somebody else to
take his place do you believe that or
does he
survive well first if Huck could be
throws his hat in the ring nobody stands
a chance that's that's just obvious uh
well there might be there might be
there's rumors that there might be a
Huckabee on the ticket though Ari uh it
might not be the one on the show but
there is rumors about
that I didn't I didn't say it would be
the good Huckabee or the very good
Huckabee uh but here here's the thing
about here's the thing about Biden and
and the Democratic Convention if he
continues to lose in the polls to Donald
Trump the Democrats especially the super
delegates going into that August
convention are going to be in panic they
don't love Joe Biden but what they do do
is hate Donald Trump so if there is a
likelihood that Don Joe Biden would lose
to Donald Trump there'll be a panic and
they're going to have to look for
somebody else I give that about a one in
three odds that that'll happen but I
also want to say Sean I think in October
those groups that you showed that are
losing faith losing support for Joe
Biden right now they're going to come
home Republicans should not fool
themselves into thinking that they're
going to do fantastic drastically better
with blacks Hispanics or younger people
they're sending signals right now that
they're very distressed with Biden I
think Donald Trump is going to do better
with blacks Hispanics and young people
but not that well those groups are
largely going to come home in October
it'll be a close
election historically that's exactly
what has happened I I think Republicans
have gotten their hopes up um I'm hoping
one day that that certain you know
identity groups if you want to call them
that they get the message that maybe
this party that comes every two and four
years and makes promises is not doing a
good job for them all right how does
this play out Governor huab
be I I think there's a better chance
that we will keep some of those voters
among blacks Hispanics and young people
I agree with Ari it's not going to be
the Magnificent numbers but some of them
will just stay home they're not going to
go vote for Joe they may not vote for uh
Trump but they won't vote for Joe but
I'll tell you what I'm watching I'm
watching mothers of four children in
Boston who are angry because the her
kids can't go to the community center
and play basketball cuz it's filled up
with illegal immigrants they're getting
gift cards she's getting shown the door
and you keep doing that through November
and a lot of those folks out of sheer
anger and frustration they'll vote for
Donald Trump and say it can't be worse
you know the the fascinating thing is is
they trying to put this on the
Republicans and everybody knows this was
policy from day one of Joe Biden um that
little game has not been SU successful
even with the help of pretty much the
entire media mob running interference
and being an extension of the the Biden
campaign uh press office anyway
appreciate you both Ari fler thank you
Governor thank you